[Music]
we're all excited for The Incredibles -
so let's keep up the hype by checking
out some of the most popular theories
people have managed to come up with in
the past 15 years stay until the end to
hear how one of the sweetest characters
could actually view a villain in the
second movie don't forget subscribe to
the things hit that notification valve
to keep up with our videos and check out
our community feature now let's check
out these theories Edna mode is a
supervillain who doesn't love this
absolutely spunky fashion designer that
easily steals just about every scene
she's in
Edna truly is a special character but
this theory states that she might
actually have a bigger secret what have
you been doing on lighting here our work
we're all familiar with one of her lines
about not dwelling on the past distracts
from the nap which connect to the fact
that she was actually a villain back in
the day the theory also states that Edna
is overzealous about seeing heroes in
danger which is quite strange for
someone that's supposedly all good and
of course we have to talk about her
actual facility which is full of
explosives and pretty unusual for
someone whose character seems like it's
the exact opposite of explosive she also
doesn't seem to like her guards even
though they're there to keep her safe we
all know that no villain has ever had a
good relationship with guards unless
they works for them but one of the
biggest facts that supports this theory
comes from the moments where she made a
suit for Jack Jack the bar family never
really considered a suit for Jack Jack
because they never assumed he'd be in
danger
but because Edna thinks like a villain
she was able to predict syndrome with
target Jack Jack okay this one's pretty
believable it was an inside job redditor
honeybee hounds had an interesting
theory that focuses on the government
because let's be honest what theory
doesn't this redditor states that the
government agents from the first movie
had a job to watch the supras while they
were retired in order to make sure they
don't reveal the
selves to strangers but even though
their job was to watch the supers they
really didn't do their job considering
how many supers actually disappeared so
how come those government agents did
nothing to stop this the redditor
carries on saying that the agents were
probably working with syndrome as he was
the best solution when it came to
dealing with the supers supers
disappearing was actually financially
beneficial to the agents as they didn't
have to spend money protecting them
anymore
in exchange syndrome was making
high-technology for the government as we
all know he was a business entrepreneur
and such high-class entrepreneurs have
to have high-class clients so why not
the actual government syndrome would be
totally capable of creating something
amazing for the government especially if
you take our next theory in
consideration although let's be honest
this theory makes the first movie pretty
dark super intelligence this theory also
comes from Reddit and it belongs to
Frank West 21 CP who stated that
syndrome actually has a secret power
it's super intelligence at the beginning
of the movie we see buddy aka syndrome
admitting that he has no powers but yet
he's actually inventing some pretty
impressive stuff we see rocket boots
life signs
scanning probes of battle robots and
plenty of really useful gadgets so what
if syndrome did have a superpower and it
was super intelligence you obviously
have to know a lot of stuff to be able
to invent such amazing pieces of
technology syndrome also made a lot of
dumb mistakes throughout his life that
could simply be because he's not so good
when it comes to thinking on his feet
there's no denial that he's a smart
cookie but what makes this theory so
dark is the fact that his super
intelligence made him develop a big ego
which cost him his life as he began to
underestimate his enemies we've heard of
villains with big egos before so this
wouldn't be so far-fetched but it's sad
if you think about the fact that how
much of his talents was actually wasted
by Lee
and snug all good and slightly dark
theories come from reddit and this one
is no different
reddit user desi underscore long de 101
possibly solved the question that's been
bothering us all
why does violet have black hair Rolla
mrs. Incredibles hair is red and mr.
Incredibles hair is blonde
it seems suspicious that a child
wouldn't have the same hair as one of
her parents right and let's not forget
about her head shape Disney takes
genetics into consideration when
creating their characters so often kids
will have the same hair or eye color as
one of their parents well unless there's
a hidden story somewhere in there that's
exactly what this redditor suspects did
you notice the parents don't have the
same hair color as violets but do you
know who does snug the redditors theory
states that because of Bob's inability
to maintain a steady job Helen would
have slept with snug before supers were
outlawed snack provided her with a
so-called shoulder to cry on which then
developed into something more and we all
know Helen keeps a picture of snug next
to the picture of her family Helen even
tells Snug that he owes her when he lent
her a jet without asking there's
definitely something going on between
those two and that something must
definitely be violet Monsters Inc
connection this theory isn't necessarily
dark but it's so cute we absolutely have
to talk about it a residue by the name
of Audra Tron had an in-depth theory of
the connection between The Incredibles
and monsters Inc since Monsters Inc came
out three years before The Incredibles
it's not so far-fetched to think this
would be true this redditor states that
when Sulley and Boo play hide and seek
Celia's amazed how good boo is at hiding
their editor thinks had booze actually
using her powers as violet aka being
invisible both violet and Boo also
struggled to use her powers when they
need to because they don't have the
confidence let's not forget that they
also pretty much look alike the redditor
also added that Randall would be the
perfect scarer for boo since his
so-called invisibility power would be
ideal for a child that's actually coming
to terms with their superpowers it's
also strange how booze so comfortable
with Sully despite the fact that he's
clearly a monster and every one of us
would be definitely scared of him it
Sulli actually reminds you of her own
father aka mr. incredible down syndrome
we're telling you if you ever want to
know more about theories you should
check out reddit this theory comes from
a user called and recalled too it states
that syndromes name is quite suspicious
and it would be very strange if it's not
connected to down syndrome the redditor
states that buddy AKA syndrome has a
flat face poor muscle tone and several
other physical features that could
potentially indicate he has Down
syndrome we also know that Down syndrome
varies when it comes to affecting mental
intelligence and can sometimes not
affected at all syndrome already has
pretty high intelligence and this
predator claims that he is in fact a
super which would have awakened his
powers is blocked by a sad condition the
theory also states that this is the
reason why mr. incredible snubbed buddy
aka syndrome when he was a child and
it's why buddy once revenge we've
already discussed a theory that states
syndrome is actually a super so maybe
combining that with his possible
condition would explain quite a lot
about his behavior what do you think
what happens to Jack Jack this theory
comes from a Reddit user called spaz
underscore myth underscore Hans and it's
a pretty popular one the user states
that Jack Jack comes out as the
strongest and most overpowered superhero
in history but that there's a reason
behind this he possesses all sorts of
powers which is pretty impressive
considering some of the superheroes
still struggle with controlling theirs
well it could be that Jack Jack is
showing all those powers because he's
unable to control them and they're still
developing the redditor states that his
powers will focus and become a single
and cohesive set of powers over time he
wouldn't be the first character to go
through this so there's definitely a
possibility this amazing superhero trait
will fade over time which to be honest
it's quite a sad thought we'll have to
see what happens in the second movie
because we're pretty sure all of this
and more will be explained when the Parr
family sees Jack Jack used his powers
they're not amazed it's probably because
they've seen this happen before and more
likely every young super goes through
the same thing the power family
she has superpowers that depends on
their personality - has super speed
because he's impatient
violet gets invisibility because she's
shy and so on Jack Jack will probably
develop a single power over time and we
can't wait to see what that will be no
capes this theory originally came from
4chan and tumblr however the original
creator isn't exactly known remember
Edna's new cape speech because one of
her friends called Strato gal had her
cape cotton and jet turbine just take a
step back and think about that for a
second her cave got caught in a jet
turbine this most likely isn't something
that she could survive shadow gal was
actually gifted with the super powers of
flight which is pretty awesome but the
dark and sad story states that she saved
a commercial jet airliner out of the
steep dive when her cave got caught in a
jet turbine and since Emma designed her
cave it's most likely that her rule
comes from feeling incredibly guilty
over the fact that the Cape was the
reason why Strato gal passed away it's
even worse when you think what edna must
have gone through when she looked
through her designs and started taking
out every single cape she made but
despite her grief and her no cape role
she knew exactly at what moment she
really should make a cape and yep it was
for syndrome and the intention behind it
was very clear let's be honest this is
pretty dark fifteen-year-old gap by the
time you watch this video you'll
probably know everything that happens in
the second movie so you absolutely have
to comment and let us know if any of
these theories are correct this one
states that there's a reason behind the
15-year gap we all know why Syndrome
became the villain and how the whole
thing ended but did you notice Syndrome
said he was getting revenge for the snub
which happened 15 years ago yep exactly
15 years ago it seems quite strange that
this connection would be coincidental
enews takes this story further and
speculated that this will relate to the
sequel and syndrome or someone else
might be seeking revenge for the events
that took place 15 years earlier 15
years is a long time but soon the wait
will be over and we'll be able to see if
there's actually any pattern going on
here imagine these poor animators had to
wait all this time just because someone
decided that
would be the entire punchline let's just
hope we don't have to wait another 15
years if they decide to make the third
movie because honestly we can't go
through this again - goes bad our final
theory is the darkest of them all but it
also ties in with the second movie
you'll absolutely have to come back here
and tell us which one of these theories
turned out to be true most importantly
if this one did a reddit user called
Professor underscore wonder posted this
theory a few years ago their editor
questions who will be the villain in the
second movie and comes up with a pretty
solid theory that it's going to be -
he's always told to rein in his super
power and restrain himself - is a middle
child and middle children are known to
be the peacemakers and the ones that
never seem to get enough attention which
is definitely the case for - in the
movie we see him prank his teachers
which gains positive attention from his
father middle children often don't get
enough attention so it's pretty possible
that - would act out like this
the redditor states that the second
movie will talk about a former suit
maker who's in hiding and wants to get
back with the supers by creating a suit
for - this suit would give - his
family's power by turning into a villain
and continuing to do negative things -
we'll definitely receive the intention
he needs what do you think plausible and
that's it for our video thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]